>> Steve: PRESIDENT BIDEN
INSISTING RECESSION IS NOT
INEVITABLE IN HIS FIRST PRESS
INTERVIEW SINCE FEBRUARY THE
10TH.
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF ALSO
ADMITTING, QUOTE:  PEOPLE ARE
REALLY, REALLY DOWN.
THE NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH IN
AMERICA, IT IS SKYROCKETED
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE SEEN
EVERYTHING UPSET.
BUT MOST OF IT, THE CONSEQUENCE
OF WHAT HAPPENED.
WHAT HAPPENED AS A CONSEQUENCE
OF THE COVID CRISIS.
IS HE BLAMING COVID FOR AMERICA
BEING IN A BAD MOOD.
FOX BUSINESS HOST CHARLES PAYNE
JOINS US RIGHT NOW WITH
REACTION.
SO, IT WAS WIDE RANGING THIS
INTERVIEW.
PEOPLE ARE IN A -- HACKED OFF
BECAUSE OF COVID, HE SAYS.
AND HE SAYS THAT A RECESSION IS
NOT INEVITABLE.
DO YOU BUY THAT?
>> NO, I DON'T BUY IT I HAVE GOT
TO TELL YOU SOMETHING, WHAT WE
ARE WITNESSING RIGHT NOW IS A
FAILURE OF PEOPLE THAT WE --
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN CHARGE BY
EPIC PROPORTIONS.
BOTH HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM.
JEROME POWELL AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
NOT LISTENING TO THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN NOT LISTENING.
KNOW WHAT THEY HAVE DONE FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS THEY TOLD US HOW
WE FEEL INSTEAD OF LISTENING TO
US TELLING THEM HOW WE FELT.
SO NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE
ALL SURPRISED.
POWELL IS SHOCKED AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
ALL HE HAD TO DO WAS VISIT A
SUPERMARKET A COUPLE TIMES.
THAT'S ALL HE HAD TO COULD.
PRESIDENT BIDEN THE SAME THING.
I GOT TO TELL YOU THIS IS VERY
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THE
ARROGANCE OF SAYING, YOU KNOW,
FIRST TO YOUR POINT, HE HAS
BLAMED EVERYTHING.
AND NOW TRYING TO EQUATE THIS TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS THAT
CAME FROM THE LOCKDOWNS INSTEAD
OF BEING HONEST.
JUST BE HONEST ONCE.
IT'S NOT TOO LATE.
YOUR POLICIES HAVE WRECKED THE
AVERAGE LIVES OF AMERICANS AND
WHAT'S REALLY THE SAD PART
BECAUSE WE ALL MAKE MISTAKES IS
YOU DID IT DELIBERATELY.
YOU DELIBERATELY WANTED GASOLINE
PRICES TO GO HIGHER.
YOU DELIBERATELY DID THIS.
YOU DELIBERATELY HAVE TAKEN THIS
GREAT NATION AND YOU HAVE GOT IT
WOBBLY BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
CHANGE, FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE TO
BORROW PRESIDENT OBAMA'S OLD
SAYING THEY FUNDAMENTALLY WANT
TO CHANGE WHO WE ARE AS A
NATION.
THE WAR ON CAPITALISM, THE WAR
ON FOR PROFIT CORPORATIONS.
RIGHT NOW IT'S OIL COMPANIES.
BUT ANYONE WHO IS IN BUSINESS,
WHETHER YOU OWN A STORE ON MAIN
STREET, ANYONE WHO IS IN
BUSINESS WHO IS TRYING TO MAKE
MONEY, MAYBE BUY A HOUSE OR SEND
THEIR KEDS TO COLLEGE, BE WARNED
THIS IS A WAR ON YOU AS WELL.
>> Steve: ONE OF THE THINGS HE
WAS RESPONDING TO THE
INSINUATION BY THE A.P. REPORTER
LOOK, THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS AND PEOPLE FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, ACTUALLY,
WHO HAVE SAID THAT A LOT OF THE
INFLATION THAT WE GOT WAS
BECAUSE OF THE GOVERNMENT
SPENDINGS.
THE GIGANTIC GOVERNMENT
SPENDING.
BUT YOU REMEMBER THIS:  REMEMBER
ONE OF THE CRITICISMS BY THE
OBAMA PEOPLE AT THE TIME BACK
WHEN THEY WERE PUMPING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS INTO THE ECONOMY WAS,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE DIDN'T GO BIG ENOUGH.
WELL, NOW, JOE BIDEN IS
PRESIDENT AND THEY WENT FULL
TILT.
>> BY THE TIME PRESIDENT BIDEN
GOT INTO OFFICE WE HAD ALREADY
AUTHORIZED $14.9 TRILLION.
TRILLION, TRILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAD ALREADY AUTHORIZED IT AND
GIVEN OUT $10 TRILLION OF IT.
WE ALREADY HAD 10 TRILLION.
WE CAME UP TO 2021 STRONGEST
HOUSEHOLD BALANCE SHEETS IN
HISTORY.
THE STRONGEST CORPORATE BALANCE
SHEETS IN HISTORY.
MOMENTUM AND VACCINE NO NEED FOR
THE EXTRA MONEY.
PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO WORK
CREATED THIS YOU KNOW THIS YEAR,
STEVE, NOT A SINGLE MONTH HAS
SMALL JOB BUSINESS HAD JOB
GAINS.
EVERY SINGLE MONTH THIS YEAR
HAVE LOST EMPLOYEES.
THEY CAN'T COMPETE IN THIS WORLD
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
CREATED.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH?
YES.
THE OWNERS OF THOSE WHO WORKED
20, 30 YEARS SAVED ALL THEIR
MONEY I'M GOING TO OPEN UP
SANDWICH SHOP AND USE GRANDMA'S
RECIPES AND WE ARE GOING TO MAKE
IT YES WE ARE.
NOW THEY ARE SUFFERING AND HE
SHOULD CONTEMPLATE THAT AND
REALLY TAKE IT TO HEART.
HE?
HAD A POSITION OF POWER TO
CHANGE IT ALTHOUGH I FEAR HE
WON'T.
>> Steve: WHY WOULD HE?
HE HAS GOT THE MIDTERMS.
HE KNOW'S IT'S GOING TO BE A
BLOOD BATH.
>> YOU CHANGE IT BECAUSE YOU
CARE ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
YOU REALLY DO.
LISTEN THESE FOLKS WHO GO TO
COLLEGE AND PROFESSOR TELLS HIM
ABOUT ALL THESE WONDERFUL THINGS
OF SOCIALISM AND IT SOUNDS SO
WONDERFUL.
IT'S FAIR, IT'S NICE.
BUT IN REAL LIFE THE APPLICATION
OF IT WHICH BY THE WAY WE SAW
LAST YEAR WE SEE THE
CONSEQUENCES NOW.
>> Steve: SPEAKING OF
CONSEQUENCES IT SOUNDS LIKE ELON
MUSK HAD A ALL HANDS ON DECK
MEETING YESTERDAY.
HE HELD UP HIS SMART PHONE.
WORLD'S RICHEST GUY.
DIDN'T EVEN HIRE A CAMERAMAN.
TAKING PICTURES OF HIMSELF.
THEY SAW IT HERE'S ONE OF THE
THINGS HE SAID.
MUSK SAID HE IS IN FAVOR OF
MODERATE POLITICS AND PRETTY
CLOSE TO CENTER.
ANSWERED WOULD ALLOW A DIVERSE
RANGE OF VIEWS ON THE PLATFORM
INCLUDING EXTREME VIEWS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF THE
LAW.
HE ALSO SAID HE WOULD LIKE TO
GET TO A BILLION USERS AND WHEN
ASKED IF HE WAS GOING TO SLASH
JOBS, HE SAID RIGHT NOW COSTS
EXCEED REVENUE AND THAT'S NOT A
GREAT SITUATION.
>> THAT'S BUSINESS 101.
ALTHOUGH HE DID SAY IF YOU'RE A
TOP PRODUCER YOU CAN WORK FROM
HOME.
IF YOU ARE A SLACKER BRING YOU
KNOW WHAT IN, BECAUSE WE MAYBE
TO SHORE YOU UP A LITTLE BIT AND
MAKE SURE YOU BELONG AT THE
COMPANY.
>> Steve: CHARLES BELONGS WITH
THE COMPANY AND IS HE GOING TO
BE HERE THROUGH THE AFTERNOON
AND WATCH HIM ON FOX BUSINESS
HERE AT 2:00 THIS AFTERNOON WITH
MAKING MONEY.
>> THANKS A LOT.
>> Steve: ON WALL STREET WE ARE
LOSING MONEY.
>> RIG